Here's the code. It's just 20 lines or so.
I've left out a couple pieces to give you something to do,
but let me first try to explain how it works.
We take a pattern and a text.
We're breaking down the pattern into its components.
The components are an operator and then and x and a y part, depending on the definition.
For example the literal will only have an x component.
Sequence and alternative will have both and x and a y.
We'll see how that component is written later,
but for now just assume it's going to pick out the right pieces.
Then we decide which operator we have, literal, sequence, alt, and so on,
and return a proper set accordingly.
For example, if the operator is asking for literal string x,
we ask does the text start with x?
If it does, then the remainder will be a singleton set, a set of just one element,
which is the remainder of the text after we've broken off the length of text characters.
If we matched a three-character sequence for x,
we return the text without the first three characters.
If x was 1 character, we return the text without the first character.
Otherwise, we return the null set. There's no match.
The alternative is particularly nice.
It says if we have an alternative between x and y
we just return the union of the those two match sets.
This character, the or bar, means "union" in Python, the union of two sets.
Sequence is a complicated one.
It says if we're asked for a sequence of x and y,
we first find a matching set for x.
That's going to be a set of possible remainders, and we go through all of those.
Then take the remainder of that text, which would be t1.
Then match y against that remainder.
For each of those alternatives, that's what we're going to return in this set.
For example, if this is our pattern--seq(star(lit('a')) plus(lit('b')))--it looks like that,
and we're matching against "aaab" then the x is the star(lit('a')),
and y is the plus(lit('b')), and the matchset for x is this set here.
We try to match y, the plus(lit('b')), against all of these match sets,
and it'll fail to match against each of these three.
It will match against this one, and so now we have a match that consumes the entire string.
The result from the match of this sequence of x and y
will be the set consisting of just the empty string,
because we've matched off all the a's and one b, and there's no remainder left over.
Note that there's a big difference between the outcome of saying
here's a result consisting of one string, the empty string,
versus the set that is the empty set.
The empty set is a failed match,
and the set consisting of the empty string is the successful match.
Now let's see if you can fill in your code for these two missing cases here.
Remember, you're going to be returning a set of possible remainders
if the match is successful.